la vie parisienne
et le monde du cinéma et du shop
business c'est quelque chose qui vous
plaît
dans lequel vous vous sentez bien
je reste pas bien définir ce que c'est
que le monde du show-biziness
l'impression qu'il est multiple quand
même que
c'est vrai que ça peut en rapport avec
ce que je connaissais de la vie
bruxelloise du coup ça m'amuser comme un
comme un jeu de société où tu vois des
codes nouveaux
je regrette la complicité mais tu sais
quand tu as ton chéri tu rigoles il y a
des sorties il y a plein de souvenirs
voilà il y a des moments intimes etc
donc ça va là mais après je regrette pas
le fait qu'on est partagé ma meilleure
amie qu'on est parti
moi franchement je repensais à mon ex et
je regrette vraiment de l'avoir trompé à
la fin de notre relation j'aurais dû
faire dès le début
allez
[Rires]
encore 20 secondes
alors pour te dire mon plus grand atout
c'est un peu compliqué parce que déjà
j'ai eu un bon patrimoine génétique
hérité de mes parents et sont tous les
deux très grands mon père fait un mètre
96 et ma mère fait 1m78 je crois si ma
mémoire est bonne donc déjà la taille
j'ai une grande envergure aussi et c'est
important quand on marche d'avoir un
d'avoir une grande envergure